[Music]
[Applause]
that was the new york mets with a
walk-off win in the first game of a
double header with the philadelphia
phillies last night
they dropped the nightcap but remain in
control of the national league east
the mets now with a five-game lead as we
approach the all-star break
a good return so far on the team's 196
million dollar payroll
but included in that figure is nearly
1.2 million for a player
that hasn't played for the team in over
20 years and one the mets will continue
to pay
for another 14 years the now infamous
arrangement involves an athlete and
owner
and the most notorious ponzi scheme in
history
at citi field there is finally something
for mets fans to smile about again
a first place team with a new owner
bankrolling baseball's third
highest payroll but we were there to
talk about the salary of a player
who hasn't been on the roster in decades
bobby bonilla gets paid over a million
bucks a year
for not playing baseball for the mets
it's become more of a joke you know than
anything else bobby bonilla day that's
right
bobby benia day the unofficial holiday
every first of july
that celebrates the mets independence
from their former slugger bobby benia is
about to get 1.2 million dollars
even though he's been retired for about
20 years the unbelievable story behind
that
is a key chapter in devon gordon's new
book on the mets
so many ways to lose it's sort of a
definitional moment of what it is to be
a met fan
the nuts have won the world series in
the mid 1980s the mets were
on top of the baseball world just five
years later most of the stars
were gone and the team finished 20 and a
half games
out of first place he was going to be
the heir apparent
bring us back to the glory of 1986 win
world series
bobby bonilla has left the pittsburgh
pirates after six seasons he signed as a
free agent with the new york mets
in 1991 the mets made benia the highest
paid player in baseball history
here's a cbs news report from the time
bobby bonilla will make 29 million
dollars over the next five
years a figure that surpasses the gross
national product of some third world
countries
the marriage seemed perfect because
bobby bonilla was from new york but
the real problem was that team stunk it
was a terrible
team and it went disastrously wrong
right from the beginning
to the point where the mets basically
ran them out of town but the mets
weren't done with benia they ran him out
of town once
and then they traded for him again and
randomly and then ran him out again
which was when the now infamous deal was
cut
deferring payment for a decade on the
final six million dollars owed to benia
freeing up the cash they used the money
to sign an ace named mike hampton who
pitched spectacularly for the mets
got them into the subway series in 2000
and then my hampton
leaves after the season as a free agent
which means the mets get a compensatory
pick
okay in the upcoming draft and they use
that pick on david wright
the third base cornerstone for the next
decade and a half so it's hard to
imagine that
deal working out better for the mets
until team owner fred wilpon
became collateral damage in an historic
case of financial fraud
investors are still wondering today if
anything is left
of the billions they invested with wall
street investor bernard made off
madoff cleans out the will ponds in 2009
but they're still broke in 2011 on july
1st when those checks start kicking in
bobby bonilla was the highest paid
outfielder on the mets
roster in 2011 making 1.2 million and
he'd been retired for
years that doesn't sit well with
anything it doesn't sit well with the
fan base
if the mets are in good financial shape
would anybody have ever even
sort of scoffed at this at all it's a
rich guy's pocket change and no one
cares
over the years benia has been asked
about the arrangements
a lot's been made of your med contract
he's been reluctant to talk about it
hey bobby how you doing man i'm doing
great but did respond to this question
from tmz sports in 2017. you're gonna
get paid a million dollars plus
until 2035. how did your agent negotiate
that
he's a special young he's a special man
dennis gilbert
help me out with that this was kind of
what we call non-qualified deferred
compensation
we caught up with dennis gilbert that
was when you were playing baseball i was
playing
baseball a former minor league ball
player michael was an
insurance client turned insurance agent
to the rich and famous
who used the same long-term principles
from the insurance industry
to become a high-powered sports agent
barry was one of your
clients right by his estimate gilbert
represented a couple hundred major
league ball players at his peak
the diary of bobby benia day right there
yeah when you did this deal for bobby
what what was his reaction at the time
bobby
listened asked questions lots and lots
of questions
and said let's do it and i know you
still talk with him
what does he think now on july 1st
actually i have a picture of him
this is on a july 1st he sent you that
shot
with new ownership in place might the
mets soon smile
come july first too for steve cohen with
all his money maybe they can just put it
all together and just pay him off for
once
and for all i'm focused on this year
steve cohen the billionaire former hedge
fund manager who bought the mets in
october
shared his idea with a fan on twitter
let's take a vote
how about we have a bobby bania day
every year hand him an oversized check
and drive a lap around the stadium could
be fun
that's an idea devin gordon a diehard
mets fan
says he's rooting for well what is that
old saying
comedy equals tragedy plus time right it
seems like we can embrace this now a
little bit more we can all enjoy the
joke
can bobby benia be here on july 1st and
you celebrate the day
i hope so that's what i'm hoping for
maybe his last check that would be great
you know the fact that this farce comes
back around and everybody's enjoying at
the end that's who the mets are anyway
[Music]
[Applause]
so they will celebrate on july 1st mets
fans will i want to say we did reach out
to steve cohen we reached out to bobby
benia both
declined our request for interview but
things seem to be
thawing a little differently now that
cohen is the one paying the bills it's
kind of cool that cohen has embraced it
i mean
what else can you do honestly it did
work if you look at the players they got
out of this deal not having to pay that
money at the time and again now that
cohen has the money well he earned it
didn't he i mean it was
part of the deal yes was part of the
deal and it's kind of like when you win
the lottery and you choose to get it
over 20 years right
what do they call that deferred payment
now mess fans get the grom on the mound
this afternoon right that's right
going for the best pitching season of
all time